pause you probably remember this
prolific 90s fad but what you may not
know is that pogs have roots that go all
the way back to 17th century Japan okay
first things first let's review the
rules to play you start with the stack
of pogs all facedown player 1 take the
slammer and throws it down into the pile
and keeps any and all pogs at land
face-up pogs that remain facedown are
Rhys tact and the game continues on the
player with the most part at the end of
the game wins hooray the origins of pogs
can be traced back to this menko a
classic Japanese game players threw
cards at their opponent's cards with the
gold flipping them over in the early
1900's Japanese immigrants settled in
Hawaii and brought the game with them
over time it evolved into a version
played with milk and juice caps from a
local dairy company in Maui eventually
renaming it pogs after their juice that
was made out of passion fruit orange and
guava get it in 1991 this woman a
sixth-grade teacher named blossom gal be
so introduced the game to her class her
goal is to teach the math but in a fun
way and it worked
big time kids loved it and the game
exploded in popularity throughout Hawaii
and then spread to the mainland as the
game took off this marketing guy Alan or
Pinsky took note he purchased the
trademark for pogs founded the world Pug
Federation and got them into every store
in America and subsequently into nearly
every home with a 90's kid pause thanks
Alan
you